i am just resting obviously
um
i still have more testing to do i hope
to be out of the wheelchair soon and
walking
jenna jameson is sharing a new update
about her health hey guys i wanted to
pop on and let you know what was going
on
on tuesday the model posted this message
to her instagram story
jenna reveals she's now back at home
following a month-long stay in the
hospital as doctors try to figure out
what caused her to lose the ability to
walk
i still have more testing to do
but
it seems there's something
off with my femoral nerve
and it's affecting
my strength in my legs
jenna continues to use a wheelchair at
this time but she hopes it's a temporary
situation
so
um i am still in a wheelchair
unfortunately
but um yeah
i hope to be out of the wheelchair soon
and walking
so you can see i still have movement in
my leg but
my quad strength is really
really really
weak
before signing off jenna assures fans
they shouldn't be concerned by her
appearance and as you can see
i have some atrophy happening my legs
are incredibly skinny but
don't get too alarmed because
my legs have always been ultra skinny so
you know
don't judge me
we will be back to the best soon denna
was first hospitalized on january 5th
hey guys so i am still in the hospital
but i'm doing okay and i'll be out soon
both jenna and her partner leor bitten
shared frequent updates about her
progress on january 10th he explained
that she'd been throwing up for a couple
of weeks and began to lose feeling in
her legs
she wasn't able to walk to the bathroom
she was falling on the way
back or to the bathroom and then i would
have to pick her up and put her in bed
and then
and then it within two days it got
really
not so good her legs started to
to
not older
she couldn't she wasn't able to walk
lior took jenna to the hospital where
doctors initially believed she had
gillen beret syndrome a rare
neurological disorder where the body's
immune system mistakenly attacks the
nervous system causing muscle weakness
and temporary paralysis
yeah
so i just
had
an infusion
we're just working towards getting
better
but a week later after doctors started
treating her for the disorder they
determined that it was not
guillain-barre affecting the 47 year old
thank you for everyone thank you really
appreciate
and jenna appreciates too even though
sometimes she can't say
thank you to everyone but uh thank you
for everyone for the
well wishes we really appreciate that
thank you god bless you
[Music]